mere equation problems can be
intimidating when you first deal with
them and that's not because the mere
equation is all that difficult it's kind
of easy it's just a few fractions added
together the place where it gets tricky
is deciding whether these should be
positive or negative so there's a bunch
of positive and negative sign decisions
that you have to make and if you make
even one of those incorrectly you can
get the wrong answer so let's do a few
mirror equation problems and you can see
how the signs work now i have to warn
you everyone has their own sign
convention there's a lot of different
sign conventions when you deal with
optics the one i'm going to use is the
one that i feel like most textbooks are
using these days and it's the one where
anything on the front side of the mirror
so by front side your eye should be over
here somewhere so let's say your eyes
over here
right you're looking at
some object maybe it's an arrow or a
crown right here a blue crayon you're
holding in front of this mirror right
here so this is the mirror right here
and the convention i'm using is that
anything on this side of the mirror is
going to be counted as positive so if
it's a focal point on that side positive
if it's an object distance on this side
it's positive and if the image distance
comes out positive you'll know that it's
also on this front side of the mirror
anything that comes out negative so if
we get a negative image distance after
we do our calculation we'll know that
that thing is behind the mirror that
kind of makes sense negative like behind
positive like in front so this side over
here is in front of the mirror positive
and back here would be behind the mirror
and that would be negative so i've got
some numbers in here already let's just
solve this one so what do we do we're
going to use this mirror equation we're
going to say that one over the focal
length and already we have to decide on
a positive or negative sign so this
mirror the way it's shaped right here
based on how we're looking at it is a
concave mirror and with the sign
conventions we just discussed and the
signs i'm using in this formula concave
mirrors always have a positive focal
length so in other words since this
focal point is four centimeters from the
center of the mirror i'm gonna have to
plug in the focal length as positive
four centimeters
notice i'm not converting that's okay if
you leave everything in centimeters
you'll just get an answer in centimeters
so it's okay you don't have to convert
as long as everything's in the same
units and we'll set that equal to one
over the object distance just one other
warning sometimes instead of d o
you'll see this as s o for object
distance or you might see d i as s i for
image distance it's the same thing as
just a different letter so the object
distance again is on this side in front
of the mirror so it's going to be
positive 12 centimeters since it's
located 12 centimeters from the center
of the mirror so it's also going to be
positive 12 centimeters and now we're
going to add to that 1 over the image
distance the image distance we don't
know i haven't drawn the image on here
it's going to be a surprise we don't
know what this is going to be but we can
solve for it so we can solve for image
distance i'll subtract 1 over 12 from
both sides which will give us 1 over 4
centimeters minus 1 over 12 centimeters
and that's going to have to equal 1 over
the image distance
so 1 4 you could rewrite as 3 12. so 3
12 minus 1 12 is just going to be 2 12
and that's going to equal 1 over the
image distance but 2 12 is just 1 6 so 1
over the image distance is just going to
be 1 6 but that's what 1 over the image
distance is sometimes people forget to
flip this at the end we don't want one
over the image distance we want the
image distance so finally you take one
over each side and we solve and we get
that the image distance is going to be
six centimeters and it came out positive
that's important this came out to be
positive
6 centimeters so where's our image going
to be so since this image distance came
out to be positive our image is going to
be in front of the mirror so it's going
to be over here it's going to be 6
centimeters
from the mirror somewhere around here so
at this point right here is where our
image is going to be but we don't know
how big it's going to be or whether it's
right side up or upside down to figure
that out we have to use a different
equation and that equation is called the
magnification equation it says that the
magnification is equal to the height of
the image divided by the height of the
object and that's equal to
negative the image distance divided by
the object distance so it turns out this
ratio of negative image distance over
object distance is always equal to the
ratio of the height of the image over
the height of the object so what's the
height of our image going to be let's
just solve for it if we solve for the
height of our image we get that the
height of the image is going to be
multiply both sides by h0 we'll have the
negative signs already here so negative
height of the object times this ratio of
the image distance over the object
distance and now we can just plug in
numbers the height of the object it says
it's three centimeters tall right here
so it's three centimeters so negative
three centimeters times the ratio of the
image distance was six the object
distance was twelve and so if you solve
this you'll get one half of negative
three which is negative
1.5 centimeters the negative sign means
that this image got inverted so it got
flipped over it's going to be upside
down compared to what it was before and
the 1.5 is how tall it's going to be so
what we end up with is an image six
centimeters from the mirror and it's
going to be have a height half as tall
so 1.5 centimeters and it's going to be
upside down because of this negative
sign so it's going to be 1.5 centimeters
tall and upside down that's what you're
gonna see if you look into this mirror
it's like a fun house mirror it's a
weird curved mirror you'd see an
upside-down image right here it might
look like you could reach out and grab
it but it's gonna be an optical illusion
there's going to be no object there it's
just going to be the image of this
object here so that's an example using a
concave mirror what would change what if
we did this what if we took our object
so say we don't put it here anymore we
move it inside here so instead of being
at 12 centimeters we moved it to like
three centimeters what would we do
differently everything would be the same
we just would plug in instead of
positive 12 down here we'd plug in
positive three so the mirror equation
works exactly the same you still plug in
whatever that object distance is you
solve for your image distance we're of
course going to get a different image
distance but whatever you get that would
tell you where the image is and then you
would take that plug it into the
magnification equation if you wanted to
decide how big the image is going to be
and whether it's going to be right side
up or upside down so these numbers are
going to be different but you would use
this equation the exact same way now
what would happen if instead of using a
concave mirror we used a convex mirror
let's say we use the mirror shaped like
this so imagine our eye again is over
here looking at this object inside of
the mirror and we're going to see an
image of the object we're going to see
the object right here but we're also
going to see the image of the object
this mirror this time instead of concave
this is a convex mirror so its focal
length is behind the mirror so what do
we do now to figure out where the image
is we again use the mirror equation
we're going to use the same equation
we're going to have 1 over the focal
length and again i immediately have to
make a decision on the sign with the
convention that i'm using this focal
length is behind the mirror so this
focal length for a convex mirror is
going to be negative so this would be
negative four centimeters and that's
going to equal one over the object
distance well again the object is in
front of the mirror 12 centimeters so
this object distance is going to be
positive 12 centimeters and then we add
to that the image distance which we
don't know this is what we're going to
solve for so this time if we solve we're
going to have 1 over negative 4 and
again we have to subtract 1 over 12 and
that's all going to have to be equal to
1 over the image distance
so now on the left hand side we have
negative one fourth but that's the same
as negative three twelfths so negative
three twelfths minus one twelfth is the
same as
negative four twelfths and that's gotta
equal one over the image distance but
negative 4 12 is the same as negative
one third so one over the image distance
has to be equal to
negative a third and if we flip that
over we get that the image distance
finally is going to be negative three
centimeters so in other words this here
is negative one third so when you flip
that over you get that the image
distance is negative three centimeters
where is this image going to be well
since it came out negative that means
it's behind the mirror because that's
the sign convention we're using so it's
going to be three centimeters behind the
mirror so it's going to be like over
here about at this point right around
here somewhere three centimeters behind
this mirror and again if we want to
figure out how tall it's going to be
whether it's right side up or upside
down we're going to have to use the
magnification equation and that
magnification equation looked like this
it said that the height of the image
over the height of the object had to be
negative image distance over object
distance so let's just see what this
right hand side is going to be if we
just set this equal to it's going to be
negative of negative 3 is the image
distance so i have to plug in the
negative 3 and you you keep that
negative in there this negative out here
comes along always but now we have
another negative inside of this image
distance of negative 3 and the object
distance again was 12 centimeters so
what are we left with we get negative of
negative 3 which is positive 3 over 12
which is positive 1 4 and the
centimeters cancel so what this ratio
tells you which is the magnification is
that the image is not going to be
inverted this positive means it's going
to be right side up and the one-fourth
ratio means it's going to be one-fourth
as large the image i should say is going
to be one-fourth as large as the object
is going to be and the reason is this
ratio is equal to height of the image
over the height of the object so in
other words if i can multiply if i want
to multiply both sides i can say that
height of the image is equal to
positive 1 4 times the height of the
object
well the height of our object was three
centimeters in this case but whatever
your height of the object is you
multiply it by this ratio of negative di
over do and you get what the height of
the image is going to be so we're going
to get one fourth of three so we get
positive three-fourths of a centimeter
it's gonna be it's gonna be tiny this is
gonna be a little little image that's
gonna be right side up so it's gonna be
right here but it's gonna be teeny it's
only gonna be like this
three-fourths of a centimeter tall
that's what our image is going to look
like so recapping you can use the mirror
equation to figure out where the images
are going to be located the sign
convention we're using is that objects
images and focal lengths in front of the
mirror are going to be positive anything
behind the mirror is going to be
negative and you could use the
magnification equation to figure out how
tall the image is going to be relative
to the object by taking negative the
image distance over the object distance